And so you've been at NVIDIA for 4 years?
Yeah, just over 4 years.
And you have had kind of an interesting path to get there.
So tell us a little bit about your background.
So my background is actually not computing.
I believe I've never had a computing class in my life,
which is not necessarily a claim to fame,
but my background is actually fluid mechanics and plasma physics.
So from engineering days it turned out that you can't do physics without computing.
When I graduated in '96, the whole world was already moving towards that--
computing and science connected.
But I was young and it seemed much more interesting to go and write computer games,
so I went and wrote computer games for a while,
went and worked for the military in high-performance computing,
went to work for a bunch of start-ups, and somehow meandered my way around to NVIDIA.